[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité vacances des
printemps les touristes sont de retour
et c'est une bonne nouvelle notamment en
Gironde après les incendies de l'été
dernier reportage de TV 7 la chaîne du
groupe sud-ouest sur le Bassin
d'Arcachon dès le début de ce journal
les touristes et des visiteurs qui se
ruent également dans les allées des
parcs d'attraction la saison débute et
s'annonce prometteuse comme a pu le
constater Moselle TV et puis un loisir
pour certains une pratique en
compétition pour d'autres Vosges TV a
rencontré un champion du monde de
Scrabble le jeu de société qui reste
vous allez le voir une référence peu
importe sa pratique et puis en fin de
journée un spectacle extraordinaire
celui de cerf-volant par centaines dans
le ciel de Berck-sur-Mer des images
féeriques pour les petits comme pour les
grands que nous proposera oui au TV la
chaîne de la Voix du Nord et du Courrier
Picard
voilà une météo clémente et des vacances
scolaires voilà probablement le cocktail
parfait pour bien débuter la saison
touristique un retour des visiteurs très
attendus cette année surtout dans les
régions impactées par les incendies de
l'été dernier exemple sur le Bassin
d'Arcachon ou les touristes profitent
des nouveaux plaisirs locaux comme a pu
le constater à xfourcan pour TV7 la
chaîne du groupe sud-ouest
un airdeur de pointe dans les escaliers
de la dune du Pilat ce lundi pour cette
nouvelle semaine de vacances scolaires
et touristes ont bel et bien répondu
présents des touristes surpris
précisément d'en voir d'autres
en ce lundi mais en même temps ce sont
les vacances donc une influence somme
toute normale au vu de la météo comme si
la page des incendies de l'été dernier
avait été définitivement tournés
donc c'est bien en terrasse à quelques
kilomètres de là dans le quartier du
mouloir Arcachon les touristes affichent
aussi un large sourire et content de
retrouver nos petites habitudes avec nos
amis pour profiter ce midi du soleil des
bons lieux de la plage
en été donc on sait presque habillé en
été on était content de ce matin en
partant pourtant les incendies restent
une actualité brûlante pour les campings
du Pilat seul celui des Flots Bleus à
rouverts pour l'instant une réouverture
partielle qui porte encore les stigmates
des feux ce qui marque forcément les
premiers locataires des lieux on a suivi
l'actualité catastrophique hélas des
incendies etc et on se rend bien compte
en arrivant sur le site que c'est assez
terrible ce qui s'est passé et ça fait
mal au cœur pour cette si belle nature
et cette si belle région et c'est
important de venir et de revenir ici
pour voilà par participer à continuer à
faire vivre la région à faire vivre les
commerçants les commerçants ce sont
d'ailleurs montrés quant à leur
pronostic de réussite économique pour la
saison à venir
voilà il n'y a pas que la très belle
dune du Pilates qui a vu revenir les
touristes en ce mois d'avril les parcs
d'attraction aussi après une pause
hivernale bien méritée les sites
reprennent du service au programme de
cette saison quelques nouveautés pour le
plaisir des petits comme des grands
reportages près de Metz des mains
facetti pour Moselle TV
c'est l'effervescence à Walygator des
dizaines de personnes passionnées
d'attractions attendent déjà devant les
grilles 20 minutes avant l'ouverture
une sortie en famille c'est notre
première fois dans ce parc en fait on va
le découvrir en organiser ça il y a deux
trois mois je pense on voulait le faire
et dès l'entrée une surprise de taille
attend les visiteurs l'allée centrale a
été complètement transformée en village
des explorateurs c'est à partir d'ici
que vous allez pouvoir commencer vos
expéditions dans le parc dans les
diverses thématisées et à venir vous
allez pouvoir voir le village des
curiosités vous allez pouvoir tomber sur
un motel ou une bonbonnière au total
plus d'un virgule 2 millions d'euros ont
été investis dans la thématisation du
parc on est peu de parcs à pouvoir en
avoir et on arrive ici sur cette place
des explorateurs avec le cercle des
explorateurs ce restaurant parce qu'il
faut prendre des forces bien entendu
avant de partir à l'aventure pour cette
nouvelle saison a lui aussi décidé de
rénover quelques infrastructures on crée
un point de restauration on va dire
buvette restauration rapide
supplémentaire notamment au niveau de
notre nouvelle zone water jump on a
rechangé notre mère de filet en fait
c'est des cabanes dans les arbres qui
permettent c'est comme un trampoline
dans les arbres donc on l'a agrandi on a
doublé la superficie pour mettre les
bouchées doubles le site de loisirs est
en train d'aménager une nouvelle
activité pour les petits qui ouvrira à
la fin du mois d'avril donc on est parti
sur des chaises de volantes tout
simplement dans l'idée d'une
thématisation sur la forêt on a repris
un peu la forme du manège qui est un
champignon en fait à la base et donc on
a décoré notre zone dans ce thème là et
l'idée c'est de faire découvrir aux
enfants plusieurs espèces en attendant
les visiteurs férus de sensations fortes
ont déjà retrouvé le chemin des
activités on aime bien les sentiers
pieds nus l'accrobranche j'ai bien aimé
l'escalade c'est ça fait les bras et
c'est amusant si le soleil perdure tout
l'été à l'image de cette première
journée la saison
nnonce prometteuse pour ces deux parcs
mosellans
[Musique]
allez pour ceux qui préfèrent les
ambiances moins chahutés que diriez-vous
en ces vacances de Pâques de découvrir
les talents extraordinaires des oiseaux
dans la Loire la volerie du Forez
propose dans un décor médiéval plusieurs
spectacles pour mettre en avant les
capacités extraordinaires des rapaces un
reportage de la rédaction de TL7
regardez
au château de Marcilly le Châtel les
spectateurs sont au milieu des oiseaux
exposé au commissaire et du coup on
voulait faire une activité pour les
enfants pendant les vacances donc on a
pensé à venir là très sympa franchement
beaucoup de beaucoup d'oiseaux très très
variés non franchement c'est vraiment
sympa qu'est-ce que vous allez voir des
perroquets qui mangent des cacahuètes
c'est très sympa c'est pas très très
grand mais c'est suffisamment grand pour
nous qu'est-ce que vous en pensez les
enfants c'est bien les oiseaux
[Musique]
la volerie du foret accueille maximum
200 personnes en plus de la visite du
site ils ont droit à deux spectacles par
jour pour les réaliser la relation entre
les soigneurs et les oiseaux et très
importantes c'est beaucoup de temps
beaucoup de patience parce que forcément
donc alors nous on peut on ne peut
proposer à nos oiseaux que ce qu'ils
savent faire c'est à dire du vol mais
nos oiseaux voilà font pas du tout du
vélo ou des choses comme ça ils ne font
que ce qu'il sait faire c'est à dire
voler pour y participer Fenrir ce faucon
gère faux a eu besoin de deux mois
d'entraînement la durée ne change pas en
fonction de la race mais en fonction de
l'individu et celui-ci est plutôt docile
comme je savais que vous alliez
approcher le micro la caméra ce que j'ai
fait c'est que je lui ai mis ce qu'on
appelle un chaperon le Chapron c'est un
masque de cuir qui permet d'occulter
complètement la vision du rapace et un
rapace qui ne voit pas ce qui se passe
autour de lui il ne peut pas en avoir
peur donc il se détend un
oiseau sud-américain qui passe à
l'apaiser
un kilo 8 la bébête parfait alors tout
ce qui vole est léger donc c'est pas
très très lourd effectivement tu te
récompense tu as bien fait c'est très
bien
ça c'est mes doigts
et cette oisillon est née il y a
seulement trois heures ne soyez pas
surpris à la volière il y a aussi
d'autres animaux une des nouveautés de
cette année ce jeune chameau de 4 ans
voilà et si la pleine saison touristique
est encore loin les professionnels se
préparent déjà pour le rush estivale et
parmi eux certains s'inquiètent comme
les restaurateurs qui peinent à recruter
alors pour changer l'image du métier et
séduire les candidats les initiatives se
multiplient la preuve en Bretagne ou des
demandeurs d'emploi se sont glissés dans
la peau de professionnels le temps d'un
service l'occasion pour eux de découvrir
le travail en cuisine ou en salle des
précisions avec ce sujet de Mathilde
quemeder sur place
une nouvelle comme ces personnes ne sont
pas forcément du métier elles sont en
recherche d'emploi ce midi elles vont
assurer un service pour une douzaine
d'employeurs elle profite en amont d'un
coaching en cuisine et en salle pour
découvrir le métier et être le plus
professionnel possible je suis là avec
Pôle Emploi du moins appeler pour
participer à la journée et je vois
j'aime beaucoup donc je suis venu
notamment pour apprendre déjà j'avais
envie de voir ce que c'était de
travailler en cuisine car je n'ai jamais
fait encore si ça change un peu pour
c'est surtout pour valider mes
compétences et justement le parrain de
cette édition le chef étoilé Nicolas
Adam a trouvé quelqu'un en cuisine faute
de personnel il travaille en ce moment
jusqu'à 3h du matin je suis content
parce qu'il est
lui aussi est content quoi je veux dire
il m'a Amélie et je c'est vraiment un
rêve de devenir travailler après il y
aura beaucoup de travail il va prendre
soin de lui qui est pas de stress le
stress doit être positif je pensais pas
qu'on allait me choisir moi enfin
c'était pas choisir encore mais
je m'attendais pas à qui me disent ouais
c'est cool quoi donc tant mieux
à l'initiative de ce job d'éthym
original Pôle emploi et professionnels
du secteur là on est arrivé sur un côté
de plus dans la bienveillance et surtout
parler en bien du métier nous on a coté
on est un peu brut de pommes des fois et
l'accueil des salariés en entreprise
aujourd'hui c'est quelque chose qu'il
faut totalement revoir face au succès
les professionnels de la restauration
réfléchissent à étendre ce concept sur
d'autres territoires et pourquoi pas au
niveau national
Sarah elle Airi était l'invité jeudi
matin de l'émission Face au territoire
sur TV5 Monde l'actuel secrétaire d'État
à la Jeunesse a répondu aux questions de
nos éditorialistes sur le plateau
regardez il y a quelques jours vous avez
donné une interview au magazine Forbes
et vous avez parlé ouvertement de votre
coming out on va pas y revenir parce que
c'est des questions très personnelles
mais je suis une question pourquoi le
revendiquer au fond on a peut-être
l'impression mauvais vous allez me dire
que qu'on n'a pas besoin aujourd'hui
parce qu'à la limite ça c'est
contre-productif par rapport à l'effet
qui vous avez vu vous avez donné 40
parlé tout à l'heure vous avez été
violée violemment agressé dans les
réseaux sociaux est-ce que c'était un
choix d'en parler parce que quel
problème ça posait voilà c'est ça c'est
typiquement c'est c'est le plus triste
dans le fond on fait deux heures
d'interview sur l'intelligence
artificielle sur le s&u sur la jeunesse
sur la relation client français le Maroc
non sur la relation entre la France et
le Maroc sujet important d'amitié
montre-moi ça me touche je suis
binationale et dans le fond
question arrive sur et Twitter il se
passe quoi sur les réseaux sociaux et
donc comme dans l'émission d'aujourd'hui
je parle évidemment des réseaux sociaux
et de l'importance de faire rendre la
distance et je dis simplement que quand
ça touche ma famille et bien moi ça me
touche c'est vrai quand je rentre le
soir et que je vois ma mère impacter ça
me touche quand je vois ma compagne
impactée ça me touche et là il se passe
quelque chose d'assez particulier le
journaliste fait le choix de titrer sur
cette information là on peut pas me
faire le reproche de parler en toute
honnêteté qu'on me pose une question
qu'on me pose une question je réponds et
considérer que répondre vos affichages
lobbying ou je ne sais quel expression
que j'ai pu lire c'est dramatique parce
que dans le fond j'aurais dit la même
chose en parlant de mon mari de mon
compagnon où j'aurais utilisé quelque
chose de plus non genre donc finalement
mon ami et puis on laissera bien aux
journalistes de choisir le I ou le I e
ça aurait été grave
l'émission Face au territoire avec Sarah
elle a écrit la secrétaire d’état à la
jeunesse est avoir ou à revoir sur le
site internet de TV5 Monde et ce des
partenaires de l'émission Ouest-France
Nice-Matin france-anti 20 minutes la
montagne Centre France et le magazine Le
Point le reste de l'actualité marqué
aussi ses jours-ci par le départ réussi
de la sonde juice depuis le centre
spatial de courroux en Guyane c'est
désormais un voyage de 8 ans et depuis
d'un milliard de kilomètres vers les
lunes de Jupiter qui attendent cette
sonde un succès en forme de répit pour
la base spatiale guyanaise qui doit
faire face depuis des mois à de
nombreuses difficultés entre échecs
spatiaux sur fond de guerre en Ukraine
et plan de licenciement les prochains
mois s'annoncent cruciaux et les débuts
prévus d'Ariane 6 sont très attendus les
précisions au micro de Franck Chassagnon
qui s'est rendu sur place
l'avenir c'est Ariane 6 évidemment c'est
Ariane 6 qui va à la fois remplacer
Ariane 5 à la fois remplacer Soyouz qui
a un carnet de commandes qui est plein à
craquer donc on attend à Ariane 6 avec
beaucoup d'impatience mais faut pas
oublier vegacer la mise le petit lanceur
vegacé qui lui aussi un très bon carnet
de commandes qui actuellement est un peu
englué dans des difficultés mais il va
bien sûr s'en sortir et puis le futur
c'est aussi d'autres micro lanceur
d'autres opérateurs de lancement avec
les micro lanceurs donc d'autres acteurs
qui vont arriver sur le marché et qui
nous l'espérons viendront lancer ici en
Guyane en tout cas on fait tout pour
voilà eux veulent un peu moins haut au
dessus de la terre bien sûr et sont
évidemment beaucoup plus accessibles les
avions de ligne font l'objet néanmoins
vous le savez de nombreuses critiques
pour leur impact sur l'environnement un
problème que tente de solutionner une
entreprise toulousaine open Airlines
c'est son nom qui s'est spécialisé dans
le conseil en éco-pilotage objectif
aider les compagnies à réduire au
maximum leur émission de CO2 grâce à des
conseils précis et puis une base de
données portant sur 5 millions de vols
vous allez le voir des trajets plus
directs des atterrissages planifiés ou
encore des altitudes de vol optimisés
images et explications recueillies par
Clément Gassi pour la Dépêche du Midi
nos partenaires
on peut fréquemment dans certaines
conditions demander des routes plus
directes des raccourcis et là on utilise
justement tout le Big Data pour prendre
l'historique de tous les vols et
visualiser des opportunités en bleu de
route plus directes et en fonction des
conditions du jour de la météo des
performances de l'avion on va lui
préconiser finalement de demander au
contrôleur aérien et le rôle plus direct
voilà tout à fait autre chose dans cette
période d'inflation où chacun cherche à
gagner un peu de pouvoir d'achat les
contrats d'assurance sont un poste de
dépenses très important dans le
Val-d'Oise une ville a décidé d'aider
ses habitants à réaliser des économies
avec l'aide d'une entreprise solidaire
d'utilité sociale les habitants font
baisser leur tarifs d'assurance avec à
la clé plusieurs centaines d'euros
d'économiser un sujet de Christophe
Rigaud pourvia 95 dans l'Oise
ce matin samira est venu faire des
économies pour cela elle a rendez-vous
avec Dan dans les locaux du Centre
Communal d'Action Sociale ensemble ils
vont passer au crible tous ces contrats
d'assurance mutuelle santé assurance
habitation ou automobile l'objectif pour
samira est d'économiser quelques euros
face à des tarifs qui augmentent
par mois
et là ils ont augmenté ces palais 73
euros 11 pour négocier ces contrats
d'assurance la ville de
Saint-Brice-sous-Forêt a fait appel à
une entreprise solidaire d'utilité
sociale dont le rôle de conseil est
primordial on veut pas les faire changer
pour qu'il perde des garanties le
minimum c'est au moins de partir sur des
garanties similaires et effectivement de
leur faire des économies en fonction des
besoins qui pourraient avoir mais oui on
parle beaucoup du pouvoir d'achat et
notre but à nous c'est vraiment de
pouvoir l'optimiser et de pouvoir
permettre aux personnes de faire des
économies après une étude des garanties
de sa mutuelle santé samira est déjà
gagnante sur son ancien contrat déjà le
tarif a changé les prestations il y a
plus de prestations et on s'occupe de
rien les économies réalisées vont d'une
cinquantaine d'euros à plus de 1000
euros par an pour certains contrats avec
les mêmes garanties à
Saint-Brice-sous-Forêt ce dispositif
gratuit pour les habitants a été initié
par la mairie un service qui sort de la
compétence de la ville mais que le maire
assume en période de flamber des prix
c'est plein de petits plus qui feront
qu'à un moment donné malgré des
situations un peu compliquées les gens
retrouveront quand même du pouvoir
d'achat donc effectivement ce n'est pas
directement de notre champ de
compétences néanmoins faut-il sur
l'interdire je pense pas depuis la mise
en place du dispositif d'assurance pour
tous une centaine de familles ont été
accompagnées à Saint-Brice-sous-Forêt et
plus de la moitié ont décidé de changer
d'assurance avec des économies à la clé
allez sans transition dans ce journal
l'intéressons-nous à présent à une
initiative solidaire mise en place dans
l'Isère dans un supermarché de Grenoble
les seniors peuvent désormais faire
leurs courses et départ des étudiants
pratiquent quand il faut se baisser
porter ou arranger une idée développée
par une entreprise qui favorise le
contact intergénérationnel écouter ses
réactions micro de Camille Avon pour
Télé Grenoble je suis contente parce que
je rencontre beaucoup de personnes on
peut beaucoup parler en plus je suis
quelqu'un qui parle beaucoup est-ce
vraiment des super moments et c'est
jamais une contrainte ou quoi que ce
soit et à chaque fois même je serai
prête à rester beaucoup plus longtemps
ça fait très longtemps que je vais
avouer ils ont toujours été très gentil
avec moi alors c'est pour ça que je peux
pas ne pas venir ici
voilà une bien belle initiative qui a
profité jusqu'à présent à plus de 600
personnes à Grenoble et si vous vous
formiez à la piculture voilà un projet
surprenant proposé par une association
dans la Sarthe elle s'adresse à des
stagiaires curieux de mieux connaître le
métier est d'en savoir un peu plus sur
la biodiversité locale un sujet d'Enzo
Maubert pour LM TV Sarthe
c'est pour ça dans la vie ils sont
maraîchers conseillés Pôle emploi ou
professeur mais voilà que depuis
plusieurs mois ces stagiaires se forment
au Beaba du métier d'apiculteur donc la
reine a le point blanc
on est resté au chaud on va dire et puis
on a vu tout est les aspects théoriques
de la vie de de la colonie du bas
maintenant bah voilà c'est le grand jour
et on enfile la vareuse et trop contente
quoi de de mettre la main un petit peu à
la pâte et puis de découvrir vraiment
cet univers là moi je suis très contente
de ça et ça commence par savoir nettoyer
une ruche il faut les nettoyer au
chalumeau faut pas avoir peur de noircir
le bois c'est pas un problème une étape
importante car bientôt les stagiaires
recevront leur propre colonies qu'ils
vont devoir transférer d'une ruche à
l'autre pour l'élever c'est le cas
classique on reçoit une une ruche avec
une colonie qui a été hivernée donc on
vient d'acheter une colonie on les on
reçoit en général au mois d'avril donc
nous sommes dans la période et la ruche
elle est consignée il faut qu'on redonne
la ruche donc il faut transférer la
colonie dans une ruche à nous alors une
vis en miniature cachée que beaucoup
découvrent pour la première fois
on partage la même curiosité que les
apiculteurs qui sont quand même des
habitués c'est à dire qu'à chaque fois
qu'on soulève le couvercle de chaque
ruche là on se dit qu'est-ce qu'on va
découvrir qu'est-ce qu'on va voir
ça la plupart des stagiaires n'ont pas
vocation à se reconvertir l'objectif et
surtout de les sensibiliser à la
biodiversité notre idée c'est essayer de
faire passer le message que moins de
traitement chimiques moins de moins
d'intervention possible et donc
multiplier le nombre de colonies en
ayant chacun au moins une ou deux
colonies nos stagiaires donc permettent
d'essaimer c'est le cas de dire décimer
dans la Sarthe toutes nos colonies
d'abeilles noires et ce qu'on veut c'est
réintroduire cet abeille noire qui était
la baignoire locale d'origine le but de
la voulez-vous aussi devenir apiculteur
amateur un nouveau cycle de formation
aura lieu à partir d'octobre 2023
un des modables le Scrabble est encore
aujourd'hui le jeu de société le plus
vendu en France et en plus des parties
en famille et entre amis le célèbre jeu
de lettres est aussi exercé en
compétition le département des Vosges
accueillait il y a quelques jours le
championnat de France de la discipline
l'occasion pour projeter de rencontrer
avis champion du monde et un champion du
monde rien que ça de cette spécialité un
reportage de Nicolas bredart
ce bruit des petits carrés de plastique
qui s'entrechoquent vous est familier et
c'est bien normal le Scrabble reste
aujourd'hui le jeu de société le plus
vendu en France pour une pratique loisir
ou en compétition comme en selon
week-end de Pascal à Golbey où se
déroulait la 41e édition des
championnats de France classiques
comprenaient comme à la maison en un
contre un mais avec 21 matchs ou ronde
en trois jours la discipline se porte
plutôt bien pour cette chrono 50 ans en
2024 on a 13 un peu plus de 13000
licenciés actuellement 13100 on en avait
un peu plus de 15000 avant avant le
covid et on est en train de récupérer
des licencés petit à petit mais on
essaye de d'avoir de plus en plus de
jeunes on travaille aussi avec le
ministère de l'Éducation nationale on a
une convention avec eux
d'ailleurs samedi était organisé un
scrabble en simultané au niveau national
au profit des scolaires sur ces images
une vingtaine de joueurs y a pris part
au sein du collège Guy d'Omer de
Mirecourt une partie des bénéfices
servira à financer le déplacement des
jeunes au championnats de France si
jeune vosgiens y participeront l'un
d'entre eux suivra peut-être le chemin
de qui a débuté le Scrabble à Golbey et
devenu l’empathie vice champion du monde
francophone j'ai commencé tout petit je
jouais avec mes parents comme ça peut
arriver à de nombreux enfants je suppose
et un jour on a vu une annonce dans un
journal pour un tournoi ici à Golbey on
y allait et voilà on y est toujours
c'était il y a plus de 12 ans maintenant
qu'est-ce qui vous bottait et qui vous
botte encore dans le scrap quand on est
jeune qu'on fait les championnats jeunes
pour qu'on revoit un peu toujours les
mêmes personnes bah forcément ça crée
une émulation de belles amitiés l'amitié
le plaisir d'apprendre et surtout la
compétition c'est ce qui anime le
champion de France en titre et double
champion du monde Benjamin vallour venu
lui du Nord-Pas-de-Calais et qui a
découvert le Scrabble plus tardivement
j'ai eu un accident de voiture à mes 20
ans et j'étais clois très longtemps chez
moi et du coup j'ai cherché un jeu sur
internet et j'ai trouvé le scrabble sur
Internet et je me suis mis au scrabble
comme ça j'ai toujours aimé les mots je
me souviens que ma tante me disait tout
le temps je me promenais avec un
dictionnaire quand j'étais quand j'étais
jeune j'ai envie d'être celui qui est le
plus titré au monde on est plusieurs à
avoir deux titres de champion du monde
et donc j'aimerais bien aller conquérir
le troisième quoi cette année c'est en
Suisse à bulle le rendez-vous est fixé à
la mi-juillet en attendant une nouvelle
couronne mondiale Benjamin Valou a déjà
décroché à Golbey un troisième titre de
champion de France
elle est que diriez-vous d'un tour du
monde au gré du vent pour clôturer ce
journal c'est à Berck dans le
Pas-de-Calais que petits et grands ont
rendez-vous pour la rencontre
internationale de cerf-volant un
événement unique en son genre qui réunit
plus de 800 000 personnes en l'espace
d'une semaine des spectateurs éblouis
vous allez le voir par le balai aérien
de centaines de cerfs en colorés et très
impressionnant Jérôme journaliste pour
way OTV la chaîne de la Voix du Nord et
du Courrier Picard était sur place
le ciel de Berck semblerait presque trop
étroit tant qu'ils sont imposants poulpe
géants dragon et même vaisseau spatiaux
se disputent la place du cerf-volant le
plus remarquable et ne croyez pas qu'ils
veulent au hasard du vent quelques
mètres plus bas les professionnels
veillent
tu peux aller chercher une 900 kg
60 mètres
un jargon technique pour un loisir
devenu un art
ivonique et son équipe s'apprête à
lancer une douzaine d'oursons il s'agit
de ne pas s'emmêler les ficelles entre
participants on fait en sorte que ça se
stabilise au maximum et puis on
réfléchit on essaie de changer un
certain nombre de choses on est là toute
la semaine justement et ça nous permet
d'aller modifier un certain réglages
certaines positions de brides voilà et
puis bah là on a le soleil levant on
peut rien demander de plus à part
peut-être un autre ours l'une des pièces
maîtresse du cerveau liste 12 mètres de
long pour plusieurs kilos de tissus
tente de quitter le sable le vent il est
un tout petit peu trop fort mais
ça va ça va le faire là l'intérêt c'est
qu'il va se gonfler très très vite pour
regarder là il va avoir sa forme dans
voilà là c'est bon il est rempli d'air
et maintenant pour le lâcher un petit
peu et voilà une raison de plus de
garder le nez en l'air ça tombe bien il
y a de quoi faire aujourd'hui voire plus
d'une centaine de cerfs-volants en même
temps et au soleil ça pas de prix c'est
joli c'est plein de couleurs en plus il
fait beau non c'est agréable chouette
c'est vraiment chouette depuis le temps
que j'en rêvais et on est là et vous
n'êtes pas les seuls 24 délégations sont
venus de partout dans le monde pour
partager leur passion et faire de Berck
la capitale du cerf-volant moi il y a
une image qui m'a marqué l'an passé il y
avait beaucoup de vent et sur la même
ligne il y avait quatre nationalités
voilà qui qui s'entraider c'est vraiment
l'esprit parce que dans les rencontres
et dans le titre il y a ce mot rencontre
qui est très fort on est grands enfants
voilà il y a que la taille et le prix
des jouets qui ont changé des âmes
d'enfants et l'esprit de compétition qui
va avec cette semaine les 36e rencontres
compte bien battre un record faire voler
ici une quarantaine de poulpe en
simultanés
[Musique]
voilà c'est la fin de cette édition
merci d'avoir suivi ce grand JT des
territoires on se retrouve très vite
pour une nouvelle édition au revoir à
tous
[Musique]